there's you know this guy i think his
name is jake tran
jake twan jake tran shots of jake tran
my good friend jake transfer
and someone i'm incredibly proud of is
jake tran this is jake tran youtube
extraordinaire my personal friend and
overall a great guy went from a no name
website developer to over a million
youtube subscribers for those that
haven't watched this channel jake trans
puts out like movie quality production
content and known for his controversial
video business essays something that we
really admire is probably the most
entertaining informational youtube page
on the planet yes best info or
edutainment i've ever seen he is bound
to be on some kind of watch list by now
and like this [ __ ] was so far
and he has some amazing videos like like
i look at his videos now i'm like what
like this is crazy i am so proud of jake
has now reached tens of millions of
people through the platform has reached
over six hundred thousand now
approaching seven hundred thousands you
just recently hit a million subscribers
oh it's not it's not a million yet this
is actually super close
what does it have nine hundred ninety
nine thousand a hundred and thirty
subscribers oh my gosh eight hundred
ninety seven subscribers i'm a drag
train i i came across this uh youtube
channel this weekend uh called jake tran
video just came across him jeremy yeah
what i i hardly get to watch youtube oh
my gosh with arguably the most
controversial and dangerous viral video
business essay creator on the platform
yeah without further ado j tran
everybody
[Music]
i spent almost every waking hour of the
past six years of my life trying to
understand the algorithm and make it as
a youtuber
and i can finally say i've cracked the
code
but this youtube story goes much further
back than just six years and to start
the story off i'm gonna take you back to
the very beginning
so you can put yourself in my shoes and
save yourself from years of struggling
i'm gonna go over my upbringing how i
actually failed at youtube a bunch of
times because i was copying others and
how that led me to a very unique
approach to youtube that allowed me to
escape competition and create my own
unique niche where viewers only had me
to flock to so growth on youtube became
extremely easy and i'll walk you through
step by step on how you can do the same
and at the end i'm going to share with
you my plan to expand this media
business into something much bigger than
just youtube
my name is jake tran and this is how i
craft the youtube algorithm
i was born in saigon vietnam and moved
to america when i was two which is great
because i get to use the immigrant card
like many immigrants my parents moved
here with nothing to escape poverty so
that me and my sister could have more
opportunity so i ended up growing up
very poor i have far from the worst
childhood ever but all i ever knew was
poverty i remember my parents would take
me and my older sister to mcdonald's but
to save money we would bring in an ice
cooler with our own soda and me and my
sister would split a burger on the
dollar menu to save money i remember my
parents cancelling cable to save money
so all i had to watch was youtube that
combined with growing up in an asian
household with extremely high standards
where all we ever talked about was money
and our careers because they wanted the
best for us and you have a kid that
swears that he will never be poor again
i didn't have much luck socially either
i got picked on in school which made an
already introverted boy even more shy
and even more of a target for bullies to
pick on i was always the outcast always
the loser i never had many friends i was
shy awkward afraid to be vulnerable you
name it
looking back little did i know that that
craving to be accepted combined with a
burning desire to never be poor again
would make for the perfect psychological
combination for youtube
[Applause]
[Music]
in middle school i ended up getting into
three fights i was probably around 12 at
the time and i would end up winning one
of them and losing two a 1-2 record my
parents were afraid that i would become
a delinquent as they should have so my
dad put me in taekwondo
at the time i was doing taekwondo what's
tech window for us old people taekwondo
uh yeah yeah korean martial art oh
taekwondo
i thought you said tech window
you say kwando dude
just saying christ hold on
right and i instantly fell in love with
it i started progressing faster than
everyone else i started competing around
the country even once in korea and i
very quickly became an instructor in
high school it would become my full-time
job all throughout high school and while
i was in high school i started getting
really into tech channels on youtube
like marquez brownlee and linus tech
tips i would see them having fun on
camera getting free tech having sponsor
spots linus had a giant warehouse with
sets cameras and entire production crew
and i was just captivated by the idea
that you can make money doing something
so fun and creative i was sold but the
problem was i was only 16 or 17 at the
time i didn't have any expertise in
anything except for taekwondo so the
goal became obvious i was going to be
the lioness tech tips of the taekwondo
world so i launched my first channel a
channel that will remain unnamed because
i find it very cringy and i ended up
making videos on taekwondo exercises
highlight wheels of competitions i would
go to gear reviews and obviously it
didn't work
after nearly two years of just straight
grinding i only had around 5 000
subscribers to show for it pretty bad i
distinctly remember making around 200
every three months from youtube adsense
because 200 was the threshold you had to
hit to get paid out by youtube by now i
had just started college i was burnt out
from taekwondo and youtube so i decided
to throw in the towel give up on my
dream and i went with the traditional
routes
[Music]
most entrepreneurs stories go something
like this i sucked at school school
wasn't for me so i dropped out and
started my own business
my story was not so clear cuts because i
was actually really good at school i
graduated 11th in my high school and
went on to study computer science at my
community college i was a complete
academic eventually i landed my dream
job after my second year of college a
remote coding job doing front end web
developments at the time i was 19 and i
paid 40 dollars an hour which if i
worked full time hours i would have been
making around 80 000 a year at 19 or 20
not bad
and almost instantly i dropped out of
college never even getting my
associate's degree at the time i was so
happy i thought i had made it but then i
started the job and it was very novel at
first but that novelty soon started to
wear off fast like within six months or
so and soon i found myself banging my
head against the keyboard at the time i
was watching a lot of personal finance
and investing content on youtube and i
thought this was the time to give
youtube another shots so i quit my dream
job and enter into round two of trying
to crack the algorithm
[Music]
at the time i was a huge fan of graham
stuffin one of the biggest names in the
finance investing space
and the number one advice you'll hear
about making it on youtube is that you
just have to be consistent consistency
is key if you're consistent you'll
eventually blow up so i basically
consistently copied graham stefan every
single week for another year straights
the same video topics the same editing
style the same thumbnails and titles
basically the exact same videos and
obviously it didn't work
so
growing up trying youtube
i always heard the number one advice of
just be consistent just be consistent
with your content and eventually you'll
blow up
that's a complete lie because no matter
how many times you put out the same
video consistently if it's a bad video
it's still going to be a bad video no
matter if you upload it once or a
thousand times consistently based on
that alone
this premise of just being consistent
and blowing up is not true so you need
something else other than other than
being just consistent what i found is
that you have to be both consistent and
offer something different something
innovative
in terms of content that isn't being
offered by the marketplace
already whether that be youtube or tic
tok or whatever i was a year into my
second try at youtube and i had a
whopping 347 subscribers to my name
see you want to imagine youtube as a
competition a competition between your
video versus others
this competition can be on the youtube
home page the sidebar and search results
etc and the competition is this whose
video is going to be clicked on more
knowing that that's the case that this
is a competition to see who can be
clicked on more and which video is
watched more also known as click-through
rate and watch time if i made the exact
same video as graham stefan for example
the exact same title and thumbnail the
exact same script editing everything
where every variable is the exact same
except for the channel name the profile
picture the face in the thumbnail and
who is on camera whose video is gonna
get clicked on every single time his
video where he already has the high view
counts where his channel name and face
is already well known and recognizable
where his video has the verified channel
badge or mind that has none of that i
think you know the answer by now
i was really copying graham stefan back
then yeah and i realized that you know
even if i have like the same title
thumbnail script exact same words as he
does yeah the only difference is me
being on camera talking instead of him
if you put those side by side on the
youtube home page who would you rather
click on graham stefan with the verified
badge 100k views versus someone like me
who you don't know what my name is and i
have like 10 views you would always
click on grams every single time so you
can never win so the only way to get
people to click on you is to offer
something completely different every
moment in business every moment in the
youtube ecosystem happens only once
that's why the next mr beast is not
going to be making game show type videos
the next in a nutshell is not going to
be making the same style of animated
science videos the next pewdiepie is not
going to be making the same exact word
videos as pewdiepie and that's why the
next jake trent is not going to be
making jake train videos
and if you try to copy these creators
you are not learning from them each one
of these titans did something
drastically different than what was
being offered before that's why copying
doesn't work
that's why in youtube you need to
innovate just like any other business
if you truly understand and internalize
this concept you will be set for life
and when you copy someone there's like
an inherent ceiling yeah
you can reach which is how big the
person you're copying is sure that's why
copying doesn't work a lot of people
when they go into youtube they start off
by copying the people they watch which
is a good place to start but it's not
going to get you where you want and the
reason why
is because
i go back to henry ford so do you know
how how henry ford got the idea for the
assembly line
uh i actually do remember reading it oh
you know what it probably wasn't that
book uh but i actually remember reading
but go ahead tell everybody yeah he
visited a slaughterhouse oh wow so if
henry ford only copied his competitors
there's like no possible way he would
have came up with the idea for an
assembly line because that wasn't in
like like all the data points he could
have got from his competitors would have
never concluded making a summing line
sure he had to visit some other niche
some other industry to another industry
that you you're pretty much pulling the
idea from yeah it doesn't have to be an
industry it can be another field of
study or whatever
to see uh to get other ideas and when i
realized this i knew i needed to change
something i knew i needed to stop
copying and that i needed to find a way
to do something completely different
that the youtube world had never seen
before and that's when i stumbled upon
the book that would change my life
how old were you when you read the blue
ocean tragedy blue ocean strategy the
blue ocean strategy blue ocean strategy
blue ocean strategy blue ocean strategy
i looked at all the factors that made up
their videos
enter the blue ocean strategy this book
basically shows you how to go into any
crowded marketplace that has a ton of
competition which we'll call a red ocean
that's full of blood from everyone
fighting over the same food and it shows
you how to carve out your own little
blue ocean with a zero competition and
gaining traction is easy because you're
the only option customers have to go to
take the wine brand yellowtail for
example the wine industry is very old
with a lot of competition wines are also
very intimidating to get into there's
too many options to where drinkers don't
know where to start wine has an acquired
taste that is difficult to appreciate
there's a whole snobby culture to it etc
and yet yellowtail emerged as the
fastest growing wine brand in the
histories of both the australian and u.s
markets being the number one imported
wine in the us surpassing france and
italy an incredible disruptive feat
by 2003 it was the number one sold red
wine bottle in america outperforming
california wines within a decade
yellowtail became one of the top five
most powerful wine brands in the world
all of this was because they created a
blue ocean they listed out all the
factors of the wine industry the price
of wine bottles how much fancy wine
terminology they used how complex the
wines are how many options there are etc
then they listed out what their
competitors did premium wines were
priced high used a lot of fancy
terminology had a lot of different
options to choose from and so on budget
wines like box ones were really cheap
still had a decent amount of wine
terminology and every other factor was a
medium amount and then yellowtail
systematically went through each factor
and decided what they wanted to increase
decrease get rid of and add they
increased the price a little higher than
budget wines but a lot lower than
premium ones they got rid of all the
fancy terminology above the line
marketing and aging quality altogether
and decreased the next three factors and
then what they did was add other factors
that the traditional wine industry never
even thought of how easy the wine is to
drink how easy and non-intimidating it
is to choose which wine to buy and how
fun and social the drink was the results
a completely different take on wine that
not only escaped competition but
completely disrupted the industry in
every sense of the word it simply didn't
steal sales from competitors it grew the
markets yellowtail brought non-wine
drinkers beer and ready to drink
cocktail consumers into the wine markets
and it completely changed the face of
the us wine industry in the span of two
years
[Music]
and this was the exact same approach i
took towards youtube i looked at the two
niches within youtube that i watched the
most number one the make money finance
investing niche like the gram stefans of
the world and number two the
infotainment niche b-roll voice over
channels like went over productions
paulie matter chris gaza etc and then i
listed out the factors that made up
those youtube videos how intellectual
the videos are the make money niche was
in the middle the infotainment niche was
high how much of a personal connection
you had with the creator the make money
niche was high since they're on camera
and you're staring at them in the eyes
for like 10 minutes straight and the
infotainment niche was very low since
they weren't on camera at all how much
storytelling there was in these videos
that make money niche was almost
non-existent the infotainment niche was
very high and a bunch of other factors
how long the videos are how visually
stimulating the videos are how much
humor there is how much selling there
was in the videos etc and then i went
through each factor and i decided which
ones i want to increase decrease get rid
of and add one of the factors i added
came from the video essay niche where
they broke down movies like the dark
knight creating the ultimate antagonist
or how to begin a movie i added the use
of movie scenes into this blue ocean i
was building you look at your
competitors you list out all the
attributes that make up like their
product in this case it's a video so
like the length of the video uh how
entertaining is it how much selling do
they do in the video
um how much of a personal connection you
have with the creator et cetera and i
basically took the stuff that i liked
removed the stuff that i didn't like
changed some stuff that i didn't like
and added other stuff that people never
thought about
and the result i still have like a
picture of this little sketch that i
made of the strategy the result was kind
of the channel i have today
really no no one really competing with
me there's actually copycats now
but yeah when you have no competition
everyone has to flock to you when i when
i started doing with stuff with stand-up
online yeah it all came from outside of
standard exactly it was it was music it
was all these other people that were
having success exactly and i was even
vloggers and i was like okay we can't
apply the same stand-up rules to this we
have to see what everybody else is doing
and then try to get inspiration from
that that makes total sense that's yeah
one of the easiest ways to innovate in
business is to just look at other
industries other industries yeah
so this has to be like business
industries and the result of this blue
ocean strategy a brand new video style
that was never seen before no one else
was making videos like this so the only
place viewers had to go to was me i made
six videos following this new format
which did just okay but then i made the
seventh video it was called why gram
stefan is killing the youtube algorithm
i posted it it did nothing significant
but then i messaged graham on instagram
about it he watches it he's amazed he
shares it on his instagram and viewers
start flooding in i'm staring at the
view count jumping out by hundreds then
thousands every time i click refresh and
within the span of 22 days this video
climbs to a hundred thousand views
to say i was ecstatic is an
understatement it was pure dopamine made
uh he made a video on i think it was on
me
and it was so detailed and he just
took a different path and knocked it up
he was making videos in the very
beginning that were basically identical
to mine i'm not saying he's copying my
videos but like the same sort of formats
style topic choice thumbnail
he
eventually switched to these amazing
documentary style videos that just blew
up out of nowhere
and now i enjoy watching his videos a
lot i mean it's like you're watching a
30-minute movie
once a week that he puts together and
they're all getting like several hundred
thousand views each i think he's closing
in on half a million subscribers i am so
proud of jake because he was able to
figure out like okay why is the current
style not working
let me switch it up let me do something
that no one else is doing which were
these documentary finance style videos
and i'm so happy for him because they
did well he found his niche he
solidified himself in that space and
it's just it's upward growth from there
and all of this happened because i
stopped copying i stopped competing and
i created my own blue ocean
competition is a sin competition
inherently leads to zero profits and as
the billionaire peter thiel says all
happy companies are different each one
earns a monopoly by solving a unique
problem all failed companies are the
same they failed to escape competition
put another way all happy youtube
channels are different each one earns a
monopoly by solving a unique problem all
failed youtube channels are the same
they fail to escape competition
build a monopoly here's a picture of the
original sketch i made way back when i
was figuring all this out
[Music]
so i finally found some traction on
youtube but i was still kind of shooting
in the dark do i make more youtuber
breakdowns like this do i try other
topics or in other words it was time to
iterate the next few videos were still
getting way more views than i ever had
but compared to the first one i blew up
they all bond somewhere along the line i
started watching a documentary on war
profiteering and i was blown away i was
so fascinated by it i was so shocked
that this wasn't common knowledge that
average people didn't know about this
but the problem was who in their right
mind would be interested in a video on
war profiteering out of all things only
nerds like me would watch this making a
video on war profiteering would be such
a waste of time but i decided to do it
anyways just to satisfy my own
intellectual thirst the viciously
profitable business of war goes live
with my guy patrick bateman on the
thumbnail and boom to my surprise it
becomes one of my best performing videos
apparently there are a lot of nerds out
there like me interested in dark
subjects like this
interesting so i kept trying other dark
topics that no one else would make
videos on the same thing happened after
i saw the movie war dogs and my
subsequent video on it how to make money
off of world war iii and then the same
thing happened with another video the
profitable business of enslaving third
world countries then the same with money
laundering the art of cleaning dirty
money and then china's profitable
business of concentration camps and then
the economics of the mafia and it just
kept going on there was a market for
these super dark videos explaining how
the world really works
and it was through these iterations that
i realized this about the world we live
in
everyone in this world wants power when
you feel like you don't have any power
you feel weak low status you fall into
depression no one wants less power
everyone wants more power the pursuit of
power is old as human nature itself and
yet chasing power is taboo in today's
world everything has to look civilized
decent democratic fair our world is
supposed to be the pinnacle of fairness
and yet greed envy lust hatred boils and
simmers under the surface as they always
have
if you stab your opponent in the back it
must be with a velvet glove on your hand
and with the sweetest smile on your face
to the outside you have to look decent
mod is civil but on the inside you
deceive manipulate outmaneuver you lure
your opponents into traps
all in the name of acquiring more power
this is the world we live in whether you
like it or not and because of all this
all the most important information in
the world is kept secret by those who
want to keep and grow their power
there's a reason why no one teaches us
about any of this there's a reason why
none of this is taught in schools and
that has become the purpose of this
channel to expose how this world of
power really works to help you navigate
this world to level out the playing
field for the powerless to help you
become more dangerous because as jordan
pearson once said a harmless man is not
a good man a good man is a very
dangerous man who has that under
voluntary control
which brings us to today
with over a hundred million views
multiple videos every week longer
private documentaries in our youtube
membership for the videos that are too
controversial to post publicly and over
1 million subscribers and counting and
the best part is that all of this is
just phase 1 phase 1 of this movement to
make people more dangerous because as
machiavelli once said any man who tries
to be good all the time is bound to come
to ruin among the great number who are
not good
the rest of this year would be focused
on pumping out even more professional
content than we already are i want every
single video of ours to feel like a
short movie and every single private
documentary to feel like a true netflix
level movie and to do this i'm going to
be heavily reinvesting money into hiring
a much larger team i'm talking better
video editors better sound designers
better voice over actors better graphic
designers everything that's phase two
netflix level content for free and more
of it on top of that i have a super big
announcement that i'm gonna review in
the next few weeks that you guys are
gonna love can't wait and when that's
all said and done then it's time for the
finale tran mafia the final phase phase
three is that we're going to be
launching our own tech startup which
i'll probably name techwindow a tech
platform that would be better than
netflix better than disney better than
hulu all of this why because those
platforms are mostly just mindless
content that just waste your life with
some good documentaries here and there
with ours you guys are gonna get access
to the best documentaries out there
documentaries that expose how the world
works documentaries that are insanely
addictive to watch that say things that
aren't allowed to be said anywhere else
documentaries that teach you how to
navigate and win in this murky world we
call home documentaries that truly have
the power to change the world
[Music]
but all of this is only going to be
possible with your help each and every
single one of you i'm talking to you
right now watching this video you have
made all of this possible thus far and i
cannot wait for you to join me on this
next chapter
stay dangerous
[Music]
you